[Sawing and hammering wood]
[Narrator:] In Latin America, a child is
dead.
Two months old, the youngest of eight children.
She was a casualty of poverty.
Another mouth to feed in a family where already
there was too little to eat.
She died of protein deficiency and malnutrition.
And her father who worked in another town did
not come to her funeral.
He could not afford to make the trip.
[Music and singing]
This instance of death is not unique.
In countries throughout the developing
world, the death of little children
is one of the daily tragedies of life.
[Music and singing]
Though we usually think of the
problem of an exploding population in
terms such as
economic development, overcrowding,
underemployment, ecology, education,
maternal health,
and personal freedom, it has come
down for these people on this day to a
matter of life and death.
[The people prepare a gravesite.]
[Dr. Madrigal:] Children dying from
starvation in underdeveloped countries
and children dying in the wars, there is
not much difference.
They are both murder.
I'm scared about the population in the
whole world, but especially in El
Salvador,
which is a place where I live, where my
children are, my wife, my work,
everything.
And it's, I'm scared, of course. That's why I'm
working here.
[Interviewer:] Is it that desperate?
[Dr. Madrigal:] Yes. I think it's
desperate, the situation, but uh,
somebody has to,
somebody has to do something.
We have to do something.
And when I say something, I am
complaining, because I want a very
strong and aggressive
policy in population, if this country is
going to be a country, a livable country
within 20 years.
[Music]
[Narrator:] El Salvador has the highest
population density in Latin America
and one of the highest population
growth rates in the world.
There are three and half million people here now,
and if something is not done, there will be seven million in 20 years.
Already one can see what this might mean in
terms of human degradation.
[Music]
Although El Salvador does not have an
official population policy,
people like Dr. Madrigal are working to
meet the challenge.
In the meantime, human tragedies
occur.
[Doctor:] I can't tell you what my name
is or show you my face,
or tell you the name of the hospital
we're in.
But I really want you to see this. It's terrible.
This girl is Ann Marie and she's been
here for about six weeks,
laying very close to death from an
illegal abortion.
This is not a unique case, we have
more than 60,000 cases like this a
year,
and this is one country alone.
As a doctor, I feel that if family planning
services were more widely available,
tragedies like this would never happen.
[Narrator:] The great number of illegal
abortions throughout Latin America and
the risks taken
by women who seek them is powerful
proof of the desire by these women
for a way to control the size of their
families.
Dr. Vernon Madrigal wants them to have an
alternative to butchering.
Among his many interests is female sterilization.
[Dr. Madrigal:] This lady is a 32 years old lady.
She has had six children ages from 11,
I think, to five years old.
And she's been taking pills in the last
five years and she's so nervous, and
she's so anxious too,
about the problem that she decided to ask us to
sterilize her.
And we are doing it with a new method called
laparoscopic tubal ligation.
I am the grantee of Pathfinder.
So we are waiting for the government application and Pathfinder will provide the funds
to those 300 tubal ligations in one year.
Okay.
[The doctor speaks in Spanish to the
other medical staff.]
She is under local anesthesia.
She's not under general anesthesia,
which represents a great advantage,
because the lady can be operated with
local anesthesia and then go home in
four hours.
[Narrator:] Dr. Madrigal got his laparoscope from
the Pathfinder Fund, an American foundation
concerned with population in developing
countries.
Along with Pathfinder and other
groups, the Agency for International
Development, AID,
the largest source of assistance and
funding in the field, is helping in an
international assault
upon the most pressing problem of the
20th century.
[Dr. Madrigal:] Okay.
[A man and woman converse in
Spanish.]
[Bill Flexner:] Some places in El Salvador are
very difficult to get to.
But getting there is part of winning the battle in
health and family planning.
The nurse that I came with, came because
there's a problem of health within the family.
After she tried to resolve this problem,
she would talk to the family about
preventive medicine
and family planning.
AID is supporting her in this effort.
[A nurse makes a presentation to a
group of people gathered outdoors.]
[Narrator:] Sex education is an important part of
the population program in El Salvador.
In a few years these children will be in
the prime reproductive age group,
and then will have the knowledge to
make intelligent decisions about family
size.
[A Filipino man speaks to a gathering
of people.]
[Narrator:] On the other side of the
world, the governor of a Philippine
province spends
spends 30 percent of his time talking
about family planning.
Like Dr. Madrigal, governor Sam Luis
is convinced that unchecked
population growth
is the greatest threat to his country.
In the Philippines, one finds the
problems of El Salvador reflected on a
huge scale.
In 1970, the government established a population
policy.
The result? In a short time the
Philippines has developed a diverse,
far-reaching
family planning program, potentially
one of the most effective in Southeast
Asia.
With help from international agencies,
large input from AID, and the energetic
efforts
of Philippine officials and volunteers,
the challenge is finally being faced.
Is it too late?
No one can say for sure.
A traditional agricultural economy is giving way to
industrialization.
The country is in the throes of a vast
migration from farms to cities.
Manila is overcrowded and mired in smog.
And its condo slums are among the worst in the
world.
[Mrs. Aldaba-Lim:] Our statistics show
today that more than 70 percent of our
people belong to the poverty line,
live within the poverty line.
I know for a fact that there are 1.5
million families in the Philippines
who live below the subsistence level.
And with this growth rate of 3.1 of
Philippine population, you can just
imagine how disastrous
this would be for the future of our social and
economic development.
[Doug Larson:] As a Peace Corp
volunteer here in the Philippines,
you see many different developmental
projects.
There are projects in agriculture,
education, infrastructure,
and yet all of these projects are
diminished because of the vast
population problem in this country.
So I feel as a volunteer working here,
it's been very rewarding to be in this
kind of program that's
that's at the crux of the matter.
[Children sing a song in class.]
[Narrator:] Children too are at the crux of the
matter.
In a class on population awareness in
an elementary school in Cabanatuan
City,
second grade students play a game:
how many of them can fit into a limited
space before the overcrowding
becomes unbearable.
How far can they be pressed before
the game suddenly becomes unfunny.
[Gov. San Luis:] God created man and all the beings on this earth.
And by nature they're all selfish as God created has created it.
And it is rather definitive that God has
given us this in order that we survive.
So every month I need to be selfish.
And in our family planning program
we're exploiting the selfishness of man
in order that we can push through our
family planning program.
Why, because we know very well that
over and above the laws of God, the
laws of society,
is the law of the stomach.
which is one of the [?] of man, the law
of the stomach.
So if you go to the barrios,
and tell the people there in the barrios
about how you can help the world,
your country,
by embracing family planning.
They would not listen to you.
But if you tell them, you help, if you
embrace the family planning program,
you'll be helping your children.
In order that they will not be
undernourished,
in order that they will be able to go
school.
So that you can give them a higher
degree of education.
It would be a very effective way, much more
effective.
And that is what we are learning.
[A man and woman walking together
call out to villagers, speaking Tagalog]
[Narrator:] When Governor Sam Luis
began his family planning programs in
Laguna,
he met resistance from the Catholic
Church.
Now the Responsible Parenthood
Council, a Catholic organization, is
working on population.
Volunteer couples visit people in their homes to
discuss the rhythm method.
In Cavite Province, Commander Borja and his
wife have made more than 50 such visits.
How are they doing? Pretty good, says the
Commander. So far, nobody's pregnant.
[Voices speaking an African language]
The home visit approach to family planning has
no national boundaries.
In the mining town of Bomi Hills, in
Liberia, Philip Koikoi
has been a professional visitor for four
years.
In that time he's called on house after
house on behalf of the Family Planning
Association of Liberia,
explaining to parents how they can
restrict the size of their families.
Later, many of these people have
shown up at the Bomi Hills Clinic,
which dispenses a large assortment of
birth prevention devices.
[Music]
Liberia has a relatively small population and is not
yet embroiled in a population crisis.
But the infant mortality rate here is
high,
and mother-child health care is below
an acceptable standard.
Though the government has no official
population policy,
the Family Planning Association of
Liberia, a private group supported by
the International
Planned Parenthood Federation,
supplies family planning services for
those who wish them,
emphasizes the health and welfare of
mothers and babies,
and instructs women on the proper
spacing of children.
[Music]
[Nurse:] Three scoops of lactic in here and you put it up, water up to six ounces,
and that's how much the baby's
supposed to have.
Okay.
Now make sure the water is boiled,
and before you come to feed the baby, you wash your hands.
[Narrator:] Mr. William Hill,
Administrative Secretary to the Family
Planning Association of Liberia,
came to the University of Chicago to
study Advanced Techniques in
Population Communication.
Mr. Hill's training in Chicago was part
of a huge effort in manpower
development,
central to the worldwide population
movement.
Over the next 10 years the movement needs
more than 50,000 physicians, 150,000 nurses,
100,000 health and family planning
home visitors,
thousands more medical and social
workers, health and family life
educators, demographers,
behavioral scientists, and
communications and training experts.
[Man holding video camera:] If it's a face, as it is a [?] face, you should have the eyes in the middle.
If you look at it...
[Narrator:] India.
After mainland China, the most populous country
on earth, over half a billion people.
If the growth rate is not checked, there will be
more than a billion people by the year 2000.
The effort here has been enormous,
the oldest and one of the largest
official family planning programs in the
world.
Twenty years of labor by hundreds of thousands
of people.
The goal: lower the birthrate by 40
percent over the next 10 years.
In India they use the cafeteria
approach, making a wide range of birth
prevention methods
easily available: sterilization,
intrauterine devices, condoms, and
other conventional contraceptives,
including pills in selected projects.
However, sterilization is the mainstay of the
program.
In the city of Coonoor in Kerala state,
one of the great innovations of the
Indian effort,
a vasectomy camp, an intensive
campaign to perform more than 15,000
operations in 30 days.
[Dr. Bernard Coehlo:] This is where all
the people come for the vasectomy
operation. Here.
[Background conversation.]
And now we go to the central room.
This is the control room where all the activities
are controlled.
Actually this is the health center of the camp.
These are the hospitals responsible for
the camp.
Here we find all the people lined up for the
operation.
They are coming from all over the district.
And not only from this district, but other
places also.
[Doctor speaks in local language to the
men in line. ]
[Dr. Coehlo:] His name is Sangara.
He is 38 years old.
He says he has three children.
His wife is 30 years old.
Why do you come here?
[Man answers in local language.]
He says he doesn't want any more
children.
He has three already.
He says his wife is willing, and he has
no objections nor does his wife have
any objections
to the operation.
[Narrator:] The operation takes less than 10
minutes.
It can be performed with scarcely the loss of a
single drop of blood.
One camp in Gujarat state, doctors
perform the incredible number
of 223,000 vasectomies in 60 days.
[Music]
There's a carnival atmosphere at the massive
camps.
Programs of live entertainment, songs and dances about the need for family planning...
prizes, inducements, awards. A whole people is behind this effort.
And Indians regard family planning as a patriotic
duty.
[Chanting]
In 1971, the Indian Parliament legalized
abortion as a maternal health measure,
part of a pattern of changing laws
throughout the world.
In Bombay, the world's first hospital
devoted solely to family planning,
surgeons have devised a method of
performing an abortion and a
tubectomy at the same time.
The Bombay program is the brainchild
of Dr. Datta Pai.
[Dr. Datta Pai:] You know this is a
fantastic station, that in more than
700,000 people pass everyday,
and it is here that the family planning history was
made.
In a city that there was only one sterilization per day, after setting up an operation here, down here,
we started doing 100, 200, 300
operations every day.
[Music]
[Narrator:] Centuries ago Arab tribes
discovered that if a small pebble is
placed
in the uterus of a female camel, that
camel will not become pregnant.
The Tunisian Institute of Family
Planning and Maternal Child Health
has chosen the camel,
the first animal to practice family
planning, as the symbol of its program,
and the bearer of an important
message to the Tunisian people.
[Music]
Tunisian Family Planning officials meet
with representatives of foreign
agencies
concerned with population.
A doctor from the United Nations World
Health Organization, a nurse-midwife
from the
Swedish International Development
Authority, a demographer from the
Population Council,
representatives of AID and doctors,
communicators, and demographers
from other groups.
They're meeting such as this in all the
countries committed to population
action.
The challenge is worldwide.
Response is international.
Standing in the courtyard of the great
mosque of Kairouan, Imam Mohamed
Ali Trad
says that family planning is not
contrary to Islam,
and it is necessary for economic
development of the Tunisian nation.
Religious leaders throughout the world are
conscious of the population project.
And many of them have found that the
idea of family planning is consistent
with their religious principles.
[Imam speaks]
The role of women in Arab society is
changing. Many have rejected their
traditional role
and now practice family planning.
Dr. Bin Sheikh, a leader in the struggle
for women's rights and the first female
doctor
in Tunisia, devotes all of her time to
family planning counseling and clinical
work.
[Nurse walks through a hospital ward,
speaking Arabic as she greets
patients.]
In Tunisia, as in many other countries, the post-
partum approach has been extremely successful.
Immediately following the delivery of a
child, women are especially responsive
to a visit
by a family planning worker, providing
information on contraceptive methods.
But it is not enough to confine the work to clinics
or to wait for people to appear.
Family planning workers must visit
remote areas, bringing information and
services and
a special kind of human understanding.
The key to all family planning programs is the
winning of acceptance.
Will the women who are contacted accept the
methods that are available?
The approach is the same everywhere,
in Tunisia, in South Korea,
in every country in the world.
One woman must talk to another.
They must be sympathetic and friendly.
[Local language spoken]
The home visit in a rural area is like a
ritual.
The lonely walk, the greeting, the establishment of rapport, the opening of the briefcase,
the display, an explanation of available
devices.
[Visiting nurse explains family planning options, speaking local language.]
The women who do this work are a new breed of
missionaries.
The often speak of their reward,
the sense of personal accomplishment when they win another woman over,
when they achieve the breakthrough
called "acceptance."
[Music]
South Korea, more than 32 million
people, a rapidly developing nation
that has reduced
its growth rate by one third in 10 years.
The goal for 1976, another one-quarter
decrease.
In the streets of Seoul, one senses the
dynamism and discipline of a people
whose country
has been transformed from rural to
urban, from farming to an industrial
power
in a few short years.
South Korea is one of the few success stories in
the battle against an exploding population.
The Korean accomplishment is a valid
inspiration to the developing world,
for it was not easily achieved.
[Family around a table speaking
Korean]
The first year birthday party of a male child.
This is a traditional ceremony in Korea,
where the preference for sons was
long a barrier
family planning, but the country is
changing.
Urbanization is leading to a desire for smaller
families.
Women are becoming better educated.
But the key factor is the commitment of the
Korean government.
It has taken 10 years of hard work to
turn the growth-rate statistics around.
[The baby begins crying.]
Faced by population disaster a decade
ago, Korea has mounted an extensive
program,
training communication, collection and
use of demographic data, a network of
mother's clubs
for family planning promotion, and even a manufacturer of condoms,
as in this factory at Onyang.
[Music]
[Dr. Ravenholt:] Since 1965, the United States
through the Agency for International Development
has provided rapidly increasing
support for population and family
planning programs
throughout the developing world.
These funds, channeled through many organizations, now especially the United Nations,
have gone for a broad scope of action
including research and provision of
contraceptives such as these,
especially oral contraceptives provided
so that poor women and couples in the
developing countries
can control their fertility as they wish,
to improve their health and well-being.
[Narrator:] The birth of a child is always a miracle,
even to those who have seen it many times.
In South Korea today, a birth is a more joyous
miracle then in most developing countries,
because as a result of an intensive program of
family planning, the future of a child is far brighter.
There should be no starvation for this Korean
baby.
The chance is good that he will have
an education, a job in a dynamic
economy,
a decent environment, and perhaps
most important, a sense of dignity.
If such things can happen in Korea, then they can
be made to happen everywhere.
In Latin America a child dies.
In Korea a child is born.
Children are the future and their destiny is in our
hands.
If the population challenge is met, then the future
holds great promise.
If it is not met, well, it must be met,
because when we speak of population,
we are speaking of the future of the
human race.
[Music]